Hello, Adrian. Hey, Chris.
Hello!
It could.
How's it going?
Doing alright.
Ohh, well...
How are you?
I'm doing good, yeah. I've been off for two weeks, so I just came back this Monday.
Kip.
Everything going okay with the family?
Not really, actually. My mother passed away, so...
And so sorry to hear that, Kip.
Oh yeah, I'm sorry.
Yeah.
No.
So how are things with the engineers? All good?
They're going okay, which is part of the reason why I have Kris on here as well. Kris works with them more in a day-to-day.
Realm, and he brought up a couple of concerns to me that I wanted to have him on here, so we could, so we could relay that and see what we need to do to fix it.
Yep, definitely.
Yeah, so some of the things that I'm seeing are just, I'm not sure if it's a language barrier or if it is just not knowing the way that we normally communicate, but I don't get enough information when they're asking questions. So it'll be, I'll get a ticket number and I'll get a very short statement.
Namit.
Mhm.
Okay.
and then I have to go and do almost all of the work to give them an answer. When I would expect that they would give me, here's the ticket number, here's the device, here's the portal that I logged into, here's the, what is this thing that I couldn't find? I would expect a lot more information when I'm asked questions.
And Chris, hi. Hi, Adrian. Hi, Chris. A quick question for clarity. When they are sharing these ticket numbers with you guys, are these tickets which are escalated tickets, they're not able to work at all? Or is it something that they're stuck with and they're expecting you to help them with?
Hello!
It's something they're stuck with and expecting help on.
Okay, okay. Because not giving information is not helpful, right? I mean, if you have to do everything on your own, you will rather work on that ticket rather than giving it to them. Yeah, okay. Makes sense. And is it with both of them, Kris?
Right.
Yeah.
Exactly.
It is with all three, actually. Santino's, he's much better, but he sometimes will give me questions that are incomplete as well.
Mhm.
Okay.
Okay, thank you for the clarity. I'll definitely make a note of it.
And Kris, any specific skill set or the technology that you think they need to work on, like any specific...
Nothing specific yet. It's just general questions about the way that diagnostics should be performed with, you know, specific device types like Datto devices, not necessarily backups in general, but Datto backups or, you know, Meraki networking equipment or whatever it might be. It's...
Okay.
our specific stack that they maybe are not as familiar with.
One of the other things that we've seen is that they are, they have not responded to any critical tickets that we've had open. There are several that we've identified and we've discussed directly with them on what they are supposed to be picking up. And those are going to be for things like data networking alerts.
when we have a device offline there or a server outage, we expect them to be the first line of defense there and at least pick up the ticket and be the contact with the customer to let them know that we're working on it. But they have not responded to any of those tickets until we actually explicitly ask them to work on it. So it's been our internal.
knock one resource, he's been handling all of our criticals.
Okay.
Chris, it's been a while that they were on boarded, right? I mean, by now I'm expecting them to be fully integrated as a part of the team. Are these signals you are seeing lately or this has been an issue from the beginning, but of course we wanted to give them some time so they're settled in.
Mhm.
Well...
I don't think I noticed it with Santino on this last issue that I mentioned. The other two, it's definitely been the entire time with everything that I've talked about. Santino, I would only have noticed any problems with him since the departure of Sarah.
Mhm.
Okay.
Since he's been the most senior from your team.
Yeah, yeah, understood.
Yeah.
Okay, so I guess next step talking about the solution, Kris, that we want to immediately jump on it from our side to make sure that these are addressed as a P1 from our side, because this is a basic expectation that we have from our engineers.
Right.
You do not really have to work with them to get them to work. We're expecting them to be proactive enough to start picking up things. And the experience should be same as what he had with Shiraj and Sterling, right? That is a similar kind of experience that we want to continue. I would want to continue this meeting on a weekly basis if we are not.
Kip, can you confirm if we are meeting on a weekly basis?
Yes, yes, it's a weekly.
Okay, all right. So Kris, one request that I have, I know that you guys are busy, but we want to connect with them today, expecting them to start showing at least the right direction and showing the results starting tomorrow. And probably midweek next week, we want to meet if that works for you.
Um...
Just to just to get a signal off, you know, are you seeing the results that we on the basis of the work that we're doing in the background? And probably we can skip the service to a meeting and again the following week we can meet at the same time. Does it work for you?
Unfortunately, no, it will not work for me. I am getting ready to actually have a kidney transplant on July the 7th. So next week I am clearing out my queue and then the following week I will be out for a while. So next, up until then I will provide my feedback to Adrian
Oops.
Ch.
Okay.
If Adrian is available, he can he can do the call with you, and then the going forward after that.
No.
Sure, yeah, thank you.
So the next two weeks, so we have the 2nd and the 9th, I'm on PTO both of those weeks.
from both of those days. So I sent my declining.
Okay.
Thank you to the invite. If we want to do a quick little 10, 15 minute check in on Wednesday the 1st, I'm available at 1 P.m. Eastern Standard Time.
Yeah.
Perfect. Okay, all the best for your surgery, Kris. And yeah, and yes, we'll put it for a 10 minutes quick check-in just to make sure that you're seeing what we are working on right as a result, just to make sure that we are moving in the right direction and we are pressing and working on the right things. Right, of course.
Yeah, that would work.
Thank you.
The bottom line is for you to see the results that we are expecting to. Okay. Cool.
Yeah, and Kris and Adrian, if you can also share some ticket numbers where you have seen these issues or things, that would be really helpful.
I, I think.
Yeah, and I know that I think we're...
I mean, are we even two months in with Grayson and Abner? I know that, I mean, they're still fresh and they're still new on our account. I think we got extremely lucky when we brought on, you know, Shiraj and even Santino too, because we had, you know, Sterling had been on our account for years at that point.
Mhm.
Yep, yeah.
and how everything operated. And I know that Sterling has been kind of also assisting and helping with these guys as well when he's available. They were more hands off and none of that being more hands on is a problem. We're just, it's not something we're accustomed to.
Mm.
Understood.
So, you know, obviously we want to, we want to help them be successful IT by design engineers in our environment and what they know working with us. We just.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yep, yep.
Just stuff that I think it's.
Just stuff that we hadn't had to do in the past, and we'll get through it together.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely, Adrian. I mean, we appreciate the transparency that we always had from you guys. And, you know, the on basic expectation that we keep from our engineers is they continue to deliver the basic stuff at least, right? They follow the right practices. And, yeah, if there is a technical challenge or if there is a technical gap,
We understand that, right? And we, of course, are more than willing to work with them to upskill them. But of course, we want the best practices to continue to be followed. So I'm confident, right, that these guys will be back on track. It's just about making them realize and helping them with some best practices they need to follow, and I'm sure they will be back on track.
Mhm.
Yeah.
We, you know, the team that I work with in person, I mean, we're very informal in our communications. It's nice and it's easy. If they feel like communication, they don't have to say, hi, Kris, or things like that out in front. They can just say, hey, I've got this thing. Can you help me out? And, you know, I mean, it's much easier if it's a little bit more informal.
Yep.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, understood. It just said, you know, probably they're taking a little bit of time. They've transitioned from our old ways of working with the previous MSP, right? They were starting with you, so that could be the time I know they're adjusting, and I'm sure that will be, yeah, yeah, but thank you, thank you for this.
Right.
Yeah, that's fine.
Kip.
I think this is something Shiraj and Sterling forgot to transfer, so we'll make sure it is.
Hoh.
Yeah, Sterling is right next to them. So we can, yeah, both of them are around. So we can, yeah, have them some time and chit chat and tell them about how they have worked. So they are still around.
Okay.
Yeah, and I...
I didn't want, the purpose of having Kris on here is not to, you know, talk bad about Grayson or Abner, right? It's just to get everybody on the same page. We want to make sure that we're all aligned on, you know, expectations and all that.
Understood.
Yeah.
I really went with, we got really lucky with Sterling and Shiraj. And I know that we can get to that point with them. And this is not us just coming on and complaining and being like, blah, blah, blah, blah. It's how can we, how can we, you know, move forward together and make this
Yeah, no, absolutely.
Make these guys as strong and technical as we can, so...
Yeah, I mean, it was fun seeing the other guys get promoted from within your team, and we'd love to help those guys get there as well.
100%, 100% Kris, 100% Adrian. Yeah, no, we understand that. And that's the reason of connecting every week so that we can help them be successful into their role. So yeah, anything that you share is certainly going to be constructive from their perspective. They know what they need to do. So.
Yeah, thank you.
Right back to you, Kip.
Yeah, thank you. So, um, so...
If you allow, I can share the deck or you want us to email you the deck how you want to.
I mean, I think if we just want to email the deck today, I'm fine with that. We need to go through all that.
Okay.
Yeah, sure, sure. No problem. No problem. I will email you the deck. And yeah, and we'll share the feedback with engineers as well, and we'll work together. And yeah, anything apart from this, anything additional?
Yes.
I have a, I created like an internal, one of our internal SOPs on kind of IT by design ticket expectations. I will.
Yeah.
I will get this sent over to you guys for review. And if you guys have any questions on anything, let me know. It talks about, you know, some of the crits that Chris was mentioning and alluding to earlier, like offline servers, offline networking equipment we get.
Kour.
So many alerts a day from one of our integrations about, you know, a switch being offline or an AP being offline, and we've been trying to gently get those guys involved, because, you know, as Kris mentioned earlier, and as our internal knock one's been handling the majority of those.
But I want to kind of spread that out a little bit more. And if we get, you know, 20 or 30 of those a day, even if most of them take 30 to 60 seconds just to confirm if it's back online or not, that, I mean, it still takes some time. So trying to get those split out and.
and all that. So I will, I'll get this PDF sent over to you guys for review. And I've reviewed it with Santino and Grayson and Abner as well. So maybe just reiterating it on your side will help some.
Mhm.
Sure.
Sure, definitely Adrian. We will definitely review and we will share our feedback as well.
Fantastic.
Well, that's a...
All right, and Adrian, one more thing I would like to share that a CSAT survey is pending, I guess, for the engineers in case.
Let me just quickly check. Give me a second.
I don't think I've gotten any CSATs for them.
And you will be getting the the thesat service for for this month as well, in a few days.
Rick.
Okay.
So take out some time and fill that out for them.
Yeah.
Course.
Okay.
All right.
All I got, guys.
Thank you, Adrian. Thank you, Kris, and best of luck one more time, Kris, with the surgery.
No.
Atul.
Thank you.
Best of luck, Kris.
Yeah, okay. All right. Well, we'll speak to both soon and we'll send the advised invite for 10 minutes, Adrian, for next week. Thank you. Take care. Cheers. Cheers. Bye bye.
Yeah, best of luck, Kris.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thanks, guys. Thank you.
Alright, thank you. Bye.
Yep, thank you. Thank you. Bye-bye.